i've had a really hard time finding
confidence it's been a long lifetime
journey
the way that i've sort of backdoored
into confidence is control
if i can control the cues that are being
sent to me if i can control the cues i'm
saying to others
it's a secret backdoor into confidence
how do you control someone else's cues
you label them and respond appropriately
so so you can't control how they act
towards you but you can control how you
react to it how you interpret it how you
transition afterwards yes like you can
first by labeling it you just controlled
your own physiology so if someone sends
you a contempt an eye roll you just took
control you took control back of nope i
see it i spot it i'm disengaging it it's
the same thing in social settings dates
professional situations negotiates
interviews the moment you say
okay i just heard an exasperated tone of
voice or i just saw a lid flex that's
the one i want to talk about now i know
i know a lid flex a lid flat is that an
eyelid yes
like a twitch or what okay so here you
asked how do we control oh yeah that's
it you just did it okay so you know
zoolander yes you know the blue steel of
course okay that is actually a lid flex
right so that's a
right it's like it's if you if you're
listening around hard on your lower lids
then like your lips that's what blue
steel is the funny thing about this cue
it's ridiculous i know you're like where
are you going at this point it makes
sense to me because it's like prove me
you're like someone's doubting you oh
you just got it okay so what's funny is
in fear our eyes widen so if you widen
your eyes as wide as possible so you can
see the whites you just i can take in
way more of my environment when we're
afraid we want to see as much as
possible
when we are trying to see details
universally across cultures we have to
lessen the light coming into our eyes so
we squint the focus we focus so if you
like if you were to try to see that dot
over there on the wall you harden your
lower lids
and that is because scientifically
proven when we harden our lower lids it
reduces the amount of light and we can
see more details without you i can see
the details on that camera better when i
lower lid flat yeah this is why if you
open people magazine's sexiest man alive
on almost every page along with a flexed
bicep are flexed lids
and that is because
women find a flex lid oh so when they
when
it's so attractive so an open lid is not
sexy is it sexy
yes because why
women and men both want partners who are
deeply scrutinizing who are deeply
looking at them so if i'm sitting when
talking to you and i go oh really
i just showed you wow that was super
interesting in fact when we flex our
lids we're going from just listening
to thinking deeply interesting we're
literally trying to see something better
so if you're in a negotiation on a date
or with a friend and they go really and
they harden their lower lids you are
like ooh ding ding i just hit something
good and so the other way that we
control cues is okay let's say that
you're this actually happened to me so
this is a story i share in the book i
was in a meeting with a very
high-powered exec team and if the
presentation went well they were going
to invite me back for more presentations
so the stakes were very high and it was
a small group and i was in a particular
part of my presentation talking about
chemicals and i noticed an executive
across the room flexed his lower lids at
me kind of flexed his lower lids he's
looking at the slide and i was like okay
what's happening he just went from
listening to scrutinizing
and so i paused the small group and i
said all good any questions and i
literally looked right at him and i
opened up my palms and i said any
questions so this is the universal
signal for openness it literally means i
want to receive i'll share anything you
are yes it's it's literally like let me
receive let me be open to you he went
yeah you know i do have a question and
at the time i was teaching about
oxytocin
i know you talk about it a lot on the
show the chemical of connection and
bonding
he goes i don't understand something
isn't oxytocin what they give women to
induce labor and i'm like you are right
sir they do give oxytocin and that's
because it's so powerful that it can
induce labor interesting but in our
position it's for social bonding
it was such a good teaching moment
because he immediately felt heard
and i know that if i hadn't addressed
that concern right then and there i
would have lost him he would have been
like what he would have been stuck on
that one slide and afterwards he said to
me you know i really feel like you were
teaching to us
to me literally teaching to him and so i
think the other way that we can control
the cues is we spot it and then we say
how can i honor it
like that's the gift that we can give
people is i can be
sitting with someone and say i want to
listen to you so deeply
i want to listen to your words i want to
watch your facial expressions i want to
listen to your number but i want to even
listen to your voice tone i mean we
haven't even talked about vocal power
which
here is incredibly important and not
only do i want to spot that i want to
respond in the way that you make you
feel the most heard by me so it's
spotting and honoring by doing that if
you're in a presentation
whether you actually acknowledge the
person or not are you just saying that
it'll bring you back to a more centered
place so you can continue on the
presentation exactly it makes you feel
in control of the narrative it makes you
feel in control of and like even for
introverts right like introverts it's
much harder for us to share a lot of
verbal content so for us i want to give
you more control over the nonverbal so
that when you do speak it's more
powerful right so if you're an introvert
and you want to make sure you are
reading the room really quickly so you
know exactly when to say your point so
it's most heard and most valued that
gives you confidence because you're not
guessing hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how to be more charismatic and confident
enjoy
rule number two build credibility with
tom bilyeu somebody that doesn't have
confidence is because they don't trust
themselves this is me literally quoting
at my let right now um and
what you have to do is build that trust
and the way that you're going to build
that trust is by making a promise to
yourself and then keeping it and so
this is where ed and i our way of
looking at this completely overlaps so
my whole thing is you want to go out and
do something that is really simple that
you know that you're going to deliver on
so for me that's always been the gym
technically i have one before that even
which is getting out of bed in 10
minutes or less which by the way full
confession time i missed today by like
20 seconds
because i got totally lost on top but it
doesn't matter so i lost a little bit of
credibility with myself today um so and
part of the reason that i say that out
loud is so that when i do it and i do it
every day that i know that i'm being
held accountable and that i get to feel
good about it when i win
and that is the other part so making
sure that you celebrate that so when i
get out of bed in 10 minutes when i go
to the gym immediately and work out that
i celebrate that and in celebrating that
and acknowledging it and fully saying
like you said you were going to do it
and you did it i'm building that
credibility with myself so that
when the next time that negative voice
comes and i want to flip it into
something positive and to remind myself
of the times that i actually did it that
i'm going to believe me i'm going to
have that credibility with myself
because i can think very concretely of a
number of times where i said i was going
to do it and i actually did it and so
that is really the key rule number three
adopt simple habits with mel robbins i
believe
with all of my heart and being that
every man woman child person grandparent
everybody
should
infuse their days with habits of
celebration and self-confidence
and the fastest and easiest and most
science-backed way
to
quickly start to change how you see
yourself
is by adopting a simple habit of
high-fiving your reflection in the
mirror every single morning
now i know exactly what you're thinking
are you serious mel robbins that is the
stupidest thing i've ever heard in my
entire life
i know
i know i know it sounds dumb
but the reason why your first instinct
when you think about waking up whether
you're in your robe or your underwear
your pjs or your birthday suit and
walking into that bathroom and having a
moment with yourself and raising your
hand and high-fiving yourself is because
your self-confidence is in the gutter
you believe some garbage about yourself
you think you're a bad person or you're
unworthy or you're ugly or nobody likes
you or how about this one this was the
story of my life i have [ __ ] up my
life
so badly
i might as well just flush it down the
toilet
you have some narrative in your mind
that is so negative that when you look
in the mirror you see somebody worth
trashing
you see what's wrong you pick apart your
appearance and i want to reverse that
because here's the deal about
self-confidence
self-confidence
begins with you
you
realize the word self is in there right
i can't give you confidence i can give
you a little boost i can give you tools
i can
encourage you
but confidence is forged in
fire it's something that's within you
and here's the thing i want you to
realize about confidence
you are a confident person
that's why you miss feeling that way you
can only miss what you know
you've just been blocked from the
feeling of it
and wherever you are right now in your
life i'm telling you confidence is in
there you just got to figure out how to
tap into it and you've been building
confidence all along by the way
every time that you have fallen on your
face or you've tried something and
failed or you've gone out and thought
you found the love of your life and then
your heart's broken and then you pick
yourself up again and then you dust
yourself you're building confidence
the entire time because confidence is
not built on the high days confidence is
built on the low ones confidence is
built when you are struggling because
when you see yourself go for something
and fall when you see yourself try and
get knocked down when you see yourself
stand back up after getting abused or
traumatized or discriminated against and
moving ahead you are building
this reserve within yourself where you
know you can rely on yourself you know
you can face hard things and you can
keep moving forward you know you have
your own back so it's in there your life
has been helping you build it now you've
got to just dig in and tap into it and
use it to shut that critic up in your
head
so the way you're gonna do that is every
morning i'm not kidding you're going to
raise your hand in the mirror and high
five yourself look at how many people
are doing this
you're not the only one for five
mornings in a row i want you to high
five yourself
and when you do this i want you to use
the hashtag high five challenge you know
what's happening when you raise your
hand up in the mirror
you are taking the lifetime positive
association that you have with cheering
for other people believing in other
people
celebrating other people
saying let's go to other people
and you are marrying that positive
association
with your reflection it is impossible to
raise your hand in the mirror and go i
suck you can't do it because your brain
and the subconscious sees this and
thinks let's go i love you i believe in
you and when you do this every single
morning something incredible happens
first of all you're not going to leave
your bathroom feeling like you're
dragging a boulder you're going to leave
there feeling like the winds at your
back
secondly you're going to have spent the
morning the first thing in the morning
by taking a moment and being with
yourself
and not seeing your face and picking
yourself apart but actually seeing the
person
that's underneath the skin the soul
that's behind the face you are going to
shut the critic up you're going to
silence your to-do list and when you
raise your hand like this it also
prompts you to think about the game
you're playing so now you've got a
moment to be like oh yeah yay me i'm
still here
i can make today a good day in fact what
game do i want to play today just for me
so that's the first thing that you're
going to do you're going to high five
yourself take the high five challenge
which is high five yourself five days in
a row in the mirror take a photo of it
post it on your story tag me so i can
cheer for you and start to notice what
happens
something weird happens by day four when
you get out of bed you're gonna have
this weird feeling that you've never had
you're gonna feel
like you're looking forward to seeing
yourself in the mirror because something
weird happens when you
start to really be present with yourself
when you normally walk in the bathroom
and you ignore yourself
you're alone
i think a lot of us feel like we're
alone in our lives
when you start to see yourself
you literally
oh
hey
hi there mel robbins how you doing you
now
as you look forward oh hey girl how you
doing hi mel robbins oh hey let's go i
believe in you gotta have a great day
it's almost like when your neighbor
waves to you you're seeing yourself you
know now that i've been doing this for a
year
i don't feel like i'm alone i feel like
i've got myself and i've got my own back
i feel like this person that i see in
the mirror
is the one person that's going to be
with me for my entire life so i better
cheer for her i better celebrate her i
better
encourage her
and love her and that's what you're
doing when you do this every morning to
yourself and there are mornings where i
stand in my underwear at my bathroom
stink and even i don't have a word to
say to myself
but i can always do this
and it always lifts my mood and it is
creating that deep connection
within me to myself and that's what
builds your confidence confidence is
being comfortable in your own skin
confidence is knowing that you have your
own back confidence is knowing that you
can face something confidence is
believing in your ability
to
face or survive or try something and
be better
and confidence is being willing to try
and all of those things happen when you
raise your hand every single morning the
second thing that you should do is um
you got to be honest with yourself
if there are things about your
appearance that are within your control
whether it is the shape that you're in
whether it's the health choices that
you're making whether it's how you take
care of yourself in terms of self-love
and you're not
taking action in those areas
the lack of action says to your brain
you don't care about yourself and so
what i want you to do is pick one thing
one behavior that you could do every day
the high fives one of them pick another
one and i want you to practice doing it
and it's a behavior if you think about
the person that you want to become
what's that person do every day that you
don't do right now
and when you start to do the thing that
the person you want to become is doing
you leverage something called behavioral
activation therapy
and that is a whole body of research
that says when you act like the person
you want to become it's the most
powerful way to change a habit
it's even uh better therapy than uh
talk therapy because the action proves
to your brain that you're becoming that
person
you're seeing the change through the
action and so then the brain catches up
and starts to relate to you like a
person that's confident or a person who
adores their appearance or a person that
celebrates themselves exactly as they
are rule number four is genuinely listen
to the people with russell brand i think
to be charismatic in conversation with
other people like say for me when i was
more interested in like celebrity
oriented things i was going on talk
shows a lot what i'd really try and do
is listen to the person that i was
communicating with or now if i'm in a
meeting or if i'm in a social situation
and i still do suffer from some social
anxiety one of the ways i overcome it is
by making a decision to really genuinely
listen to the person that i'm
communicating with and let go absolutely
of the idea of getting something from
that exchange i let go of the idea that
i'll get approval or applaud it or
anything from that exchange i tried to
channel myself into a kind of state of
how can i be of service to this person
that's when i remember to do it
sometimes of course like anybody i'm
trapped up in the uh sort of miasma of
my own self-centeredness and all i'm
thinking is i want something i'm
insecure that kind of claptrap that goes
on the stack of the mind those constant
interruptions that we're tethered to i
don't think necessarily inadvertently
because we live don't we in this shash
of our uh conventional systems our busy
cities burrowing continually into our
mind
webbing us to the ordinary never
allowing us to flourish but when i'm my
best self when i'm my higher self i
think who is this person that's before
me think of the limitless mysteries in
them access the point within them that's
the same as my own awareness when you're
talking to another human being i've had
it suggested that i took that you ought
look into their left eye that their
creative mind is the left side you know
all of that stuff that is obviously
massively reductive because neurology is
incredibly complex but the idea of
focusing on an eye looking at a person
don't do it psychotically don't stare at
a person continually some people don't
like that you don't like it do you jen
you don't like too much eye contact so
just choose it look away for a little
bit while you're talking bang a little
bit of eye contact they never look
around bang a bit of eye contact you
know look at people
listen to them
open your heart when you're
communicating to them think about your
own breath think about being present
well don't think about stay with your
own breath be present in the moment and
listen to them absolutely
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five eliminate
self-doubt with ed milette you can't win
when you doubt and you can't win when
you're discouraged
what i found out though about self-doubt
is that you don't overcome it you build
something bigger than it which means you
build your self-confidence and the
greater and greater your self-confidence
get it minimizes the impact self-doubt
has on us now why is that so important
it's important because you have to
understand one thing about the doubts
and the negative thoughts you have about
yourself
as hard as this is to accept
these are not your thoughts
you weren't born doubting you weren't
born discouraged you weren't born
thinking negative things about yourself
those were thoughts that were placed in
you
and given to you by an external source
at some time in your life it could even
be our parents
don't do that be quiet sit down be a
good boy be a good girl maybe it was
criticism you received as a as a little
one that you may not even remember to
this day it could have been a school
teacher it could have been ridicule at
school from other children but when you
were young in your formative years these
negative thoughts about yourself were
planted in you by an external source
that's so powerful to understand because
these things you think you believe about
yourself that have become really true to
you you don't even really believe they
were not your original thoughts but the
power of belief is so incredible in our
lives it's so insidious because when we
have a belief about something even if it
was given to us by somebody else
our mind goes to work on proving to us
that this belief is true a belief is
almost like this table right here just
the top once we get it and what our mind
tries to do is it tries to build legs
under the table to reinforce that belief
so if somebody told you you weren't
enough or you weren't smart enough or
pretty enough or fast enough or strong
enough or you don't come from the right
place or you're not in the right culture
the right race the right religion the
right height the right iq as a young
person or you were put down and these
beliefs were given to you what happens
is your mind tries to prove beliefs true
so it finds references so once you think
it your mind finds an example of your
life where you weren't enough another
one where you weren't enough you weren't
smart enough you weren't pretty enough
you weren't handsome enough you weren't
strong enough and it finds these
references and it builds like a leg and
multiple legs under table and pretty
soon you can't move it and it's stuck in
there as a firm belief that's why we
have to guard our beliefs so preciously
because our mind goes to work on finding
these legs these references which are
real experiences in our life to prove to
us that that belief is true and so
although you may believe it to be true
about you these doubts and negative
thoughts you have these were not your
original thoughts that's a powerful
thing to understand because you weren't
born this way you weren't born doubting
you were born perfect you were born
believing you were going to do something
great you were born happy you were born
believing you were going to do something
special with your life as a baby i
promise you you had no negative
self-talk you had no negative self-doubt
these are external sources so important
to know because those thoughts aren't
really who you are there's somebody
else's thoughts they gave you because of
how they felt about themselves rule
number six connect
share care with john ensor and when i
was trying to be charismatic early on
and failing
people were sensing there was something
that wasn't quite right but when i
stopped worrying about that and changed
the way that i was thinking that i was
charismatic people could sense it
and that if you like is the foundation
that i can build my charisma on
then we get of course the million dollar
question if the way i'm thinking can
make me charismatic what should i think
in order to be charismatic
and i'll give you a huge tip
we stop thinking about ourselves about
my insecurities
and about
all about
how great i am neither is an attractive
thought to be transmitting
telepathically
so what i do is i stop before i go on to
a big stage or into an important meeting
i stop for a moment and i think about my
audience you
and i think i like you
i think you're going to like me i've got
something great to show you and i'm
looking forward to connecting with you
sharing with you
laughing with you
and this i'm fully focused on this
moment
because you matter
charisma is
power presence and warmth also in terms
of our mindset and in this moment on the
stage i gain my warmth from the fact
that i care i care about what i'm saying
and i care about you
i get my presence from the fact that i'm
fully invested in this moment
because you matter
and i get my power
from the fact that i am confident that i
have something of value
i believe that i have something of value
to share
so i wish to spread
this idea
that rather than trying to influence one
another through being loud and
convincing and impressive
we should believe in the
magic of telepathic charisma
connecting
caring
and sharing rule number seven is do the
scary things with grant cardone where do
you get your self-confidence you can't
buy it at the store folks can't dress it
up can't eat it
you can't buy it you can't even
manufacture it yourself you have to go
build self-confidence
this is this is a topic that's near and
dear to my heart okay because i remember
being 25 years old scared to death of
people 29 years old started my speaking
career terrified of the people i had to
go to
didn't call on anybody for a year
because i was literally frozen in fear
and one day said somebody said something
to me do you need you need to handle
your self-confidence issue so i went and
bought a suit and i didn't feel any
better i went and bought a car didn't
feel any better about myself i mean i
felt a little better for a second look
self-confidence is the only outfit you
can't buy this is an inside job you got
to study you got to learn you got to
practice and you have to you have to do
the hard things self-confidence comes
from
repeating experiences that are difficult
same place courage comes from
you know the guy that does something
that's courageous is given the title of
being courageous
it's not because he went in war
courageous it's because he went and did
something look if you want to build
self-confidence you can listen to the
subliminal tapes it's not going to work
you can go do hypnotism it's freaking
ridiculous you need to be more aware
more alert and you need to do more
some of the ideas that people are
throwing at you guys right now to build
your self-confidence you're going to eat
different and feel better you're going
to do this and feel look you need to get
in front of people do the things you're
scared to do to get the self-confidence
you want to have period it's not on sale
it's not at bloomingdale's macy's it's
not a toyota it's not on the radio dude
it's an inside job i can't help you with
it you got to take what i'm giving you
in these blurbs blabs streams scopes
cats whatever you're calling it the
posts the streams the instagrams
hey man i need to take that and start
applying it in my life otherwise you're
going to find yourself feeling worse and
worse and worse about yourself you want
to go walk on fire go do it is that
going to build your self-confidence i
doubt it
okay i doubt it man go spend eight grand
on a weekend that will not improve your
self-confidence the only thing i know
for sure that will change your sense of
self is the actions you take getting in
front of other people
other people people you don't know
people you're scared to talk to you're
sitting there trembling through your
pitch
until you don't tremble anymore
self-confidence an inside job it's not a
suit you put on it's not a car you drive
this is not something you buy this is
something you develop number eight work
on your gifts with brian tracy how do
people develop high levels of
self-confidence well we found that the
flip side of self-confidence is called
self-efficacy that means
that you are good or you feel that you
are good at what you do
one of the fastest ways to build
self-confidence is to think through
clearly who you are and what you want
to think about the skills that you will
need to build a wonderful life and
career and then to work every day on
becoming better and better at something
that is important to you
what happens is as as you feel better
and better
in these skill areas people will
complement you and say you know you're
very good at that or you did a good job
at that or they'll stand back and be
amazed and as they admire you for your
improving skills your self-confidence in
your ability to do that thing goes up
and up
give you an example when i started off
in selling i didn't get any training at
all i was just told to go out and knock
on doors and make sales and i did i
wasn't afraid to make sales or to make
calls but i didn't have any skills and i
never made any sales sometimes i would
start at
seven or eight in the morning when
people came to work and i would work all
day and then i would go and knock on
apartment doors and houses right up
until nine even 10 o'clock at night
sometimes i would work 14 hours and
never make a sale now my self-confidence
was at an all-time low until somebody
came along and said you know there's a
logical proven process for making sales
starting with prospecting property
building rapport
identifying needs and so on and if you
follow the process you'll make sales so
i began to follow a process and i began
to make sales within a year my income
had gone up dramatically but my
self-confidence was so high i started to
recruit and train other people i started
to build sales organizations for the
rest of my life i had this incredible
confidence that i can learn whatever i
need to learn to achieve whatever goal i
can set for myself
and so can you self-confidence is the
result of your becoming progressively
better at something that is important to
you and as you work on yourself your
self-confidence will go up automatically
rule number nine is study yourself with
bob proctor and one of the greatest
hang-ups that people have
is the belief in themself
they they suffer from something called
self-doubt
many years ago i read something
um
it was by um
ralph waldo emerson it was this essay on
self-reliance that's what we want to do
we want to rely on self and in that he
said there would come a time in every
person's education when they realize
that envy is ignorance and imitation is
suicide
so many people look at someone that's
doing very well possibly in the same
field they're in
and envy them
do you know what that's saying that's
saying i don't know
that
i have the same mental faculties you've
got i'm drawing on the same potential
that you're drawing on there is only one
mind
i don't know that
so i'm going to envy you thinking you
can do something i'm not able to do the
truth is if you can do it i can do it
envy is ignorance it's not knowing that
and he said imitation is suicide
do you know that nothing in this
universe would move in the precise order
it moves in your absence
that's true
everything in the universe is essential
you take any part away from anything
it's not complete
and everything in the universe moves in
a very precise way so you see we
shouldn't even want to be like anybody
else because we are unique
we are truly unique there's something
like about us that
you'll never find in another person
we're unique and we've got the god-like
ability to think
now
what is self-doubt self-doubt is the
opposite of self-confidence
confidence comes from
understanding
like i would imagine you're confident
you can drive your car
in fact you're so confident that you'll
be talking to somebody on the phone
you'll get in the car you'll start the
car you'll drive and you'll drive maybe
four or five blocks not even be unaware
of what you've done it's all done
automatic your concentration is on the
conversation you're on now when you
first got in a car you couldn't do that
the car was probably jumping all over
the place and you thought you'd never
learn how to drive it but you learned
how to drive it now you're quite
confident you're confident that you can
get dressed when you get up in the
morning
when you were a little boy or a little
girl you couldn't do that you had to be
taught to do it
well do you know self-confidence comes
like all confidence it comes with
knowledge
and the more you study you the more you
understand who you are
the more confident you'll become in your
ability to do whatever it is you're
doing and you'll know that if you lack
confidence in an area it's because you
liked information in that area
get some good material out and study it
our company puts out such phenomenal
material it's material i've been
studying for over 50 years and not just
studying but demonstrating using it
we've watched millions of people go from
poverty to abundance
not by accident but by design
never doubt yourself
and when you do understand that the
cause of that doubt
is not
lying within you it's in wrong thinking
it's in not understanding who you are
study yourself
self-study will develop
self-confidence and self-confidence
eliminates self-doubt and rule number 10
the last show before some very special
bonus clips is find certainty with jay
shetty a lot of the time we don't feel
confident because we're desperately
seeking validation from others we always
ask ourselves what will people say what
would they think how would they react to
what i feel
and the challenge is that we've been
trained to ask everyone everything from
when we try on a new jacket or a new
coat and we look at our friend family
member or partner we say what do you
think i look in this
confidence comes from asking yourself
that question how do i feel i look in
this often we message our friends and
family and say where do you want to go
for dinner tonight what would you like
to do
it's really important that we also get
to know ourselves and ask ourselves what
would i like to do when we start to find
certainty and awareness around our likes
and dislikes what we feel works for us
and what doesn't work for us that builds
a sense of confidence usually when we
spend time with a lot of people we hear
a lot of noises we hear a lot of ideas
opinions expectations and even
obligations
but when you start to find time with
yourself you can ask yourself deeper
questions
ask yourself how you truly feel about
something and what your genuine beliefs
are then you can act on that internal
certainty rather than all of the
external uncertainty
self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things when you face adversity
and you tell yourself it's too difficult
you lose self-confidence when you face
adversity and you push through it you
act you go forward you build
self-confidence most people won't do
difficult things because your identity
is tied to the results you only feel
good about yourself when you win and so
you only do things where there's a
fairly high percent chance of you
actually winning and so that leads to
you playing small forever and always
doubting yourself you know you're
capable of more but you're afraid to
fail the trick to playing a bigger game
and building real self-confidence is
feeling good about yourself when you try
not when you win
celebrate the effort not the results
because you likely won't get immediate
results at the beginning especially if
you're doing difficult things but if you
tie your self-esteem to your effort and
you keep putting in the effort you will
get results to do the difficult things
you need to respect your effort more
than winning my biggest fear is around
disappointing people i hate the idea of
letting somebody down and so it used to
prevent me from taking action because i
would be so paralyzed by fear of letting
that person down that i would secretly
hope that they would cancel on me i
remember when i booked my trip to brunei
i was invited to do a keynote speech in
brunei to help their young entrepreneurs
there and i agreed to it months in
advance
and then as we started getting closer to
it
i started having many panic attacks like
oh my god it's coming up oh my god why
did i say yes to this i hope they cancel
i hope they can't so i'll be checking my
email three five eight times a day
expecting the sorry evan it's over it's
not happening you know we're not we'll
still pay you or we won't pay you it
doesn't matter but you don't have to
come anymore it's like yeah
you know i'm waiting for that email
and it never came so i had to go and
that's not just for the big things like
okay that makes sense it's in brunei
different country never been there it's
on national tv it's a big deal you can
pay a lot of money to go there great it
makes sense you're scared of that i'd be
afraid even on a on a small micro level
i remember
being afraid of meeting entrepreneurs in
coffee shops and there's one woman in
particular that this really sparked a
change for me there's one woman who i
agreed to meet at a coffee shop she was
a pure startup mode
[Music]
and i remember just before the meeting
out my email same thing i'll be checking
my email a couple times before waiting
for her to cancel on me waiting for her
to say i can't make it i'm delayed it's
not going to work and and be like yes no
problem i can go off and do something
else it never came right she never
canceled on me and so because i was
worried about letting her down i still
would have i would go to the meeting i
wouldn't cancel myself and i would not
show up because that's the ultimate
letting her down so i still had to go
and it ended up being
such a great conversation
and i remember sitting in the car
afterwards and i'm about to come home
and
i just had this fantastic conversation
with this beautiful person
and was able to help her was able to
shift her business was able to give her
a perspective that she wasn't thinking
about before was able to inject it would
believe that she was off now building a
better business for herself and i made
that happen in a really short amount of
time and this
was what made me feel the best helping
people
get to where they need to go is the
thing that fills me up the most more
than making videos
this is the thing that fills me up the
most
and i almost wish that it didn't happen
right like i i wish that it didn't
happen i was waiting for her to cancel
on me and i remember having this moment
sit in the car it's like what am i doing
[Music]
why am i so afraid of this thing the
thing that i love doing the most is the
thing that makes me the most fearful and
i almost sabotage myself and so
from that moment i decided that i need
to tie my my self-worth my actions my my
confidence to the doing
that it may not work out that chances
are it's gonna work out but it may not
work out and that's okay
that i need to show up that i need to
push through because the only way to
actually then gain your self-confidence
to gain more respect for yourself is by
doing the difficult things whether it
works out or not that takes years to
become a great chef and what you need to
do is establish confidence in in
yourself
cooking is an amazing journey
and don't think you can learn it within
three or four years it's like studying
medicine it's over a 10 to 15 year
period i'm 42 years of age and i'm still
learning new exciting things now that i
bring back to the fold
but more importantly vision i think
i didn't think french was important at
school and i kicked myself now because i
went to live in france for three years
and became bilingual but i wish i'd
studied harder with a second language on
my belt that gives you a different
culture gives you a completely different
level of confidence
learning french french cuisine mannerism
and cooking in a very robust uh
tenacious way so
yeah vision
and
open-mindedness
and we never cut corners the minute you
start cutting corners and food
time out there's no worse job to have
than to cut corners and food so
attention detail an amazing exciting
journey one of the very few jobs
anywhere in the world that you can
travel
get paid and experience phenomenal food
anywhere in the world brilliant this
will be the biggest upset since sunny
listen and i think it is befitting that
i go out of boxing just like i came in
defeating the big bad monster that
nobody could destroy a hard punch
i'm the underdog if he hits me i'm in
trouble like the sun it lets them fight
but i came back and i shook the world
and i got listened last ten years since
sunderland i'm meeting another big bad
strong monster knockout artist that
beats everybody son enlisted knocked out
patterson twice and i was supposed to
fall but he didn't knock me out
because
he could hit hard but he couldn't find
nothing yet george foreman knocked her
ken narton knocked out joe frazier
true i didn't knock him out but i'm so
fast i'm so hard hit i'm so scientific
i'm a total different man from frasier
norton listen david when i meet this man
if you think the world was surprised
when nixon resigned wait till i whip
foreign
i'm telling you david i'm down to 215
pounds right now i said it when 215 i'm
fighting weight already i usually train
six weeks for a fight i've trained four
months for fight i'm chopping trees i've
done something special
i've wrestled with an alligator
[Music]
now you know i'm bad only last week i
murdered a rock injured a stone
hospitalized a brick i'm so mean i make
medicine sick
man's in trouble
george fulman people are afraid of
george foreman they talk about how hard
he hits the world has been deceived you
listen to me now i've never told you
wrong the man don't hit hard he knocked
joe frazier down six times he got up
sixth time joe king roman is tokyo japan
fight the puerto rican champion knocked
him down three times he jumped up three
times he knocked ken martin down four
times he jumped up four times when have
you ever saw the man say seven eight
nine ten count his man out when i hit
suddenly listen to the second fight he
stayed out for the count of ten zoro
foley stayed out for the count of ten
cleveland williams stayed out for the
count of ten what few i have knocked out
stayed down sugar ray robinson knocked
him out for the count of 30. joe lewis
marciano jack dempsey jack johnson
archimo as a child they knock them out
cold
so this man has never knocked nobody out
cold he's a bully he's slow he has no
skill no footwork he's awkward and i
have been giving him a name i named
floyd patterson the rabbit i named son
and listen to bad and he shall be known
as officially as the mummy
and why why the moment because he fights
when he's fighting if you ever watch him
in the ring he he he he drags like that
after his opponent
and and how's the mommy gonna catch me
when you're fighting a mummy you just
keep a step ahead of the money see yeah
confidence this is what alpha m was all
about and what i would come to realize
was the reason that i was put on this
earth to help guys feel better about
themselves it's
it's hard for me to talk about
i had this passion and this desire to
help you
burns so deeply inside of me and i feel
it through every ounce of my body and
soul confidence this is the key
to feeling great about yourself without
it you will absolutely never know your
true potential or how amazingly powerful
you could possibly be so when i realized
that it was this confidence that i
wanted to try and facilitate in other
people i told some people about it and
they're like you can't teach confidence
either you have it or you don't
and these were people that i i did
respect and so it sort of got to me a
little bit and i thought to myself hey
maybe you can't teach or maybe you can't
learn confidence they told me just stick
to style don't talk about this other
stuff
but i decided that i wanted to keep
talking about the other stuff talk about
things that i felt were important to
develop character
because i i really did feel like hey
maybe it's going to help at least one
person
um and then something remarkable
happened i got an email it was from a
guy who watched my videos his name was
brian and he told me that
through watching my videos he actually
felt better about himself and that he
was more confident and this was like
what
i'm like really i it was the best day of
my life and um something else strange
happened i got another one
and another one and another one
gentlemen i realized that i was right
you absolutely can learn to be confident
validation confidence is a skill it can
be learned but now came the tricky part
i needed to figure out a structure and a
system how to actually walk somebody
through the steps to become more
confident it's taken me two years to
complete but i finally did it gentlemen
i am incredibly proud and pleased to
announce that the alpha m confidence
course is complete the alpha m
confidence course is a step-by-step
system to help you unlock the five
phases of self-confidence phase one is
learning and exploration you've got to
be able to take a hard look at yourself
ask yourself the tough questions in
order to drill down to figure out who
you are as a person and what has led you
to where you are now as a person until
you understand who you are you can never
move forward phase two is developing
your physical and external confidence
fitness style grooming diet all of these
topics are discussed in detail and
outlined in phase two think of it as
confidence from the outside you work on
the outside it transcends to the inside
and then phase three is all about acting
and communicating confidently phase four
is living confidently and then we're
wrapping it up with phase five which is
adoption but here's the interesting
thing about confidence and any skill for
that matter is that you need to
continually nurture and do the things
that you did in order to get to that
level of confidence so if you get to be
confident feeling good about yourself
right if you stop doing all those other
things that led you to hear guess what
the insecurities are going to creep in
confidence is not a thing it's not a
destination it's a journey that you're
going to be on your entire life how do i
gain more confidence it starts with
yourself man you got to start diving
into those things that you are afraid of
you don't gain confidence by going to
the spot that makes you feel good
it could be a false reality and the
second life gives you that challenge
all you want to do is go back to what
makes you confidence or or or what gave
you confidence is that happy spot
no
what gives you confidence what gave me
confidence was spending years at a
kitchen table
trying to learn how to read and write on
my own
realizing i can't learn the way you
learn i can't
but i can learn what gives you
confidence not being afraid
it's overcoming the fear
isis stutters severely bad so right now
i don't know how many people are going
to watch this you know what gives me
confidence is knowing i no longer care
if i sit or start stuttering to you yeah
that's what gives me confidence is
facing these things overcoming them and
maybe not overcoming them every day
but facing them
and facing their face and preaching like
this you know what man this is where
it's at
it's not in that comfort zone
it's in the discomfort zone
is where my confidence is getting built
that's where it's getting built
but people want to and they want an
easier answer yeah there has to be an
easier way
it's not i'm sorry i searched for it my
entire life we all want to be able to
change the way we feel that's what i
spend my life showing people how to do
and what most people know is the emotion
is created by motion the way you move
determines the way you feel you have 80
different muscles in your face 80. for
most people this is the largest area of
unemployment in the country you know
they use their the face the same way
they feel the same emotions over and
over and over again so what i was saying
is i have this deal with myself called
priming every day i say look
you've got to have 10 minutes for
yourself you don't have 10 minutes for
yourself you don't have a life and i'm
not going to hope i feel good i don't i
just got back six countries in 12 days i
was in india two days ago wow i woke up
here wanting like feeling like somebody
ran me over with a truck
but you got yourself psyched
but the way i did is i do this process
it's ten minutes i put some music on i
do this massive change in my breathing
so it radically changes the way i feel
and then i do this three-step process
first i do three minutes of gratitude
where i think of three things i'm really
grateful for and i associate i don't
think of it over there i feel it and the
reason is when you're grateful you can't
be worried you can't be fearful when
you're grateful you can't be angry and
anger and fear are what screw people up
most in their relationships and their
life and their business so i wire myself
i was saying to you that
most people want to be happy but their
habit is to be worried or pissed off or
frustrated or stressed and so they're
they've got a highway to stress and they
got a dirt road to happiness so i wire
myself i've got a highway to gratitude
which changes all your emotions and then
i do a three-minute process of kind of a
prayer for my family and friends and
then i do a three-minute process of the
top three things i want to accomplish i
see it as done and i feel i'm done in 10
minutes so sometimes i go 20. but my
deal is 10 so there's no excuse not to
do it decide you need no reason
whatsoever to be more confident
just make the decision to be confident
you don't need a reason you don't need
50 people to tell you you're amazing or
you're beautiful or we love you you just
have to say you know what today i'm
going to lift my head up a little bit
you know today i'm going to give myself
a little bit of credit today i'm just
going to be confident i'm going to walk
into this room i'm going to stand tall
as if i'm an incredibly confident person
for no other reason then that's my
intention right now that's it that's the
power of intention it's the power of the
self-directed human being that we just
get to choose how we want to feel you
could be happy right now for no reason
right for no reason at all you could
just say you know what
i'm deciding to be happy in my life
you don't need 50 things to make you
happy just sense the moment feel
grateful for life you're good to go
right we over complicated these things
we think we have to have you know some
big long psychological story and build
up to suddenly one day wake up and be
more confident no we don't we have to
wake up one more day and say today i'm
be confident just like we decide when we
wake up if you ever had a day where you
just i mean you just crushed it you know
you got so much done you were like wow
at the end of the day you're like man i
just crushed it today that happened
because when you woke up in the morning
said i'm gonna get some stuff done today
you had the intention to be a productive
human being that day so why not set the
intention to be a confident human being
that day why not sent the attention to
be a loving person or a an ambitious
person or a fun person or a flirty
person or a sexy person or whatever kind
of person that you want to be just
decide you don't need a bunch of stuff
people really get this one wrong and
what happens is if you don't have the
intention in the moment to say i'm going
to be confident i'm just going to allow
that to come up i'm going to feel that
sense and feeling what confidence is for
me and express that genuinely and real
for myself with in the vacuum of
intention arises impulse and often from
that impulse through our brain stem up
comes worry concern fear the the paying
attention to what is wrong so that we
can fix it or flee or escape right so we
have to have the intention of who we are
and what we're going to be it begins
with you simply deciding to be
a confident person changed my life when
i did that i i realized and this was way
back in college for me i just thought i
want to be a confident person how is
this going to happen
do i have to wait till i'm 50 after i've
achieved everything i've made some money
or maybe people like me somewhere come
on get over it
we should get over our stuff and one day
just realize real confidence is simply
having the ability to genuinely express
who we truly are and to pursue things
that we truly desire that's confidence
confidence doesn't have to mean you're
leaping over tall buildings confidence
means you're being who you are
authentically for no other reason no one
gave you permission you just decided to
be who you are you decided to chase your
dreams that's confidence right believing
in yourself and believing in where
you're going that's confidence it
doesn't take a whole lot of magic that's
confidence
one thing that skye mentioned in the
last panel about building relationships
with people before you need something
from them so really thinking about how
do you
reach out to a vc you may not be raising
funding now you may be thinking about it
but starting to build those
relationships early so cam had that kind
of relationship he mentioned mark
schuster which is he's one of the
biggest venture capitalists in los
angeles tell us a little bit about how
you cultivated that relationship and how
it grew over time um i think
i had a level of confidence that most
people don't have
and what i mean by that is
um
i try to make people relearn everything
that they think that they know about
people like me right traditionally a
rapper is just staying like oh he's just
a rapper it's a bad thing right but i
started getting frustrated with people
throwing that stuff at me and i would
change it and say you know what
being a rapper means
having your finger on the pulse of the
millennial generation right to be hot
like jay-z for such a long period of
time you have to know what the young
generation thinks you have to know what
they dancing in the club what kind of
sounds they like what kind of shoes
they're wearing what new car you have to
be ahead of the curve and you can use
that as an advantage so when they throw
this rapper thing at me i switch it
around and say nah that's what it is
right and then
a lot of the people that are out here
get putting capital in all these
companies and investing in all these
companies they don't even use the
products like a lot of y'all could
probably tell me about snap more than
they could so once i started to realize
that it just became a confidence that i
started having and i would talk to them
like no actually it doesn't work like
that it works like this and then they'll
be like what and then i'll prove them
wrong and the next thing you know
they're listening to me for insight so
it didn't necessarily happen like that
with mark susan marcus was a person that
just recognized that and he was like you
know what i like your confidence i like
your understanding of social let's just
build a relationship and it started from
there so he offered to invest in me like
five six years ago and i would i just
wouldn't take his money i was like now i
got my own money next thing you know i
started giving him my insight on all
kind of companies and i think he
understood the diverse opinion coming
into the room and how valuable that was
and that's why me and him built a bond
like that there are some people around
us who just seem like they are born with
natural confidence you know who i'm
talking about they're super smooth super
confident they always know the right
thing to say
think about president obama he just
seems like a smooth guy think of one of
his famous yes we can
rally speeches
not being political here just talking
about his oratorical skills
what do you notice about how he speaks
he's powerful
he's decisive
he speaks slowly
and almost never stumbles
or stutters
his points are clear
and they're to the point
he's the epitome of confidence when it
comes to a speaker on stage
so when you look at somebody like him
it's very easy to assume
that he has some innate ability that he
was born with either you have it or you
don't
but the truth is confidence is a skill
and president obama just like all
confident people built that skill
he practiced it over a lifetime so
here's a simple example of how you can
control your confidence in less than 20
seconds
take something you routinely say
like what you did this weekend
and change the way you say it
i want you to channel
your inner
super confident person it could be
barack obama it could be susan sarandon
it could be whoever you want don't focus
on who it is don't even worry about what
you say
instead focus on changing how you say it
sit up straight
speak slowly
and imagine what you're saying
is incredibly important
because the people listening
want to hear it
let me show you an example a little
before and after
yeah uh
i can't even remember i mean
i think it was pretty good it was
actually pretty crazy but i just went to
a movie and saw some friends you know
the usual i guess
now let's compare the after
we had a great weekend
i was with the kids on saturday then
michelle and i caught a broadway show
and finished the night at that new sake
bar downtown
now what'd you notice notice first that
i'm intentionally using someone else to
role play this really lets us get into
play acting without worrying about our
own life our own saturday ooh maybe i
don't have as cool of a life as going to
a sake bar don't worry about that
all we're doing here
is working on our delivery remember
nobody sees inside of you they don't see
how confident you are how much work you
spent practicing all they see is
the way you answer a question or the way
you sit when you're talking to them
so when it comes to confidence
confidence can actually come from the
outside in
not just from the inside out which is
what everybody tells you
so instead of waiting for it to just
magically appear where's my confidence
where is it we're actually changing our
behavior
something everyone can do and we're
letting the confidence follow the
external influences the internal and
once you master this concept you can
apply it to a lot more than just how you
speak and how you sit i always grew up
heavy set like larger than most people
in my class or my my family like the
younger girls in my family my immediate
family mum and my dad they never really
made me feel that way like in all of my
videos when i was younger i'm in front
of the camera like super happy
my mom was like an instructor like a
fitness instructor she had like six-pack
abs when i was growing up yeah she was
super fair she would kind of drag me to
all of her classes um
but
i noticed it most when i started going
to school obviously you end up seeing
people around you and the girls around
you and the type of people that
end up being liked or disliked and you
realize that actually ends up being a
lot to do with your physical form i want
to go to what you said about your mom um
having six-pack abs like did that
did it dawn on you at the time like was
there any
envy or did it make you feel badly or
you don't you would like no i was just a
happy-go-lucky kid and it was cool that
my mom had abs no i definitely felt it
like you definitely feel it from a young
age and emotionally it was more when
people would make comments about it
or when you can't fit into things or
when you see yourself in like a video
with the rest of your family or your
cousins and you're like the chubby kid
in the corner you know you don't but the
confidence level i think only changed
when i got to school and it was there
was i was surrounded by girls who i
thought were more beautiful than me or
skinnier than me and it's so weird i
always feel that now looking back
thinking that fitness was always related
to how skinny you were like that was my
my image ever growing up that's all i
thought that to be fit that means you
have to be really really slim
um and it wasn't necessarily because of
my mum but it's just what you end up
growing up looking at all over the place
is women wanting to be super slim
and in my eyes that meant for me to be
fit i had to be skinny so how did you
not let that erode your self-worth or
did it erode yourself worse i think it
definitely did because growing up your
self-worth i feel is based on everybody
around you when you're a teenager how
many guys like you or whether the guy
you like likes you back that ends up
defining whether you love yourself or
whether your friends love you you're not
stable you have no rooting and so
everything that you base your love for
yourself on ends up being external and
so i definitely had ups and downs of of
really
thinking i was something when somebody
liked me and then when somebody didn't
like me or my friends decided not to be
friends with me i would dislike myself
and so everything was based on external
validation for sure and how did you stop
that loop then or when did you remember
the first time you recognized it that it
was a loom yeah i felt that way for a
long time that i felt something was
missing i knew that my love for myself
could not be based on other people there
had to be something else that i could
have a foundation of okay fine there can
be ups and downs but i never go down to
a low where i don't love myself and i
definitely think meditation was the
turning point for me and i felt that
because it was the one time in the day
where i would end up spending time with
myself like you i feel like people don't
do that we spend time on everything to
do with hair and makeup and clothes and
on other people looking at other people
talking to other people
but i felt like i wasn't spending any
time actually thinking who am i like i
don't know who i am and i feel like in a
relationship whether it's with yourself
or whether it's with somebody else
you have to know yourself to love
yourself we never get into relationships
with people or friendships with people
without knowing them you can't fall in
love with someone without knowing them
and so i felt like okay who am i like i
actually don't know who i am i don't
know what i like i don't know why i
dislike everything that i like or
dislike is based on other people
um everything that i like about myself
is based on other people's lives
oh you've got beautiful exactly exactly
my favorite hair must be lovely exactly
and so everything is to do with oh they
like it so that must be who i am
and so i thought meditation was the
first time or just journaling was the
first time i started writing down things
about things i like about myself or
don't like about myself and so it
created more of like a relationship with
with me i was having a relationship with
myself finally rather than my perception
of myself because of other people god i
love that
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below
on this video i will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
if you want to learn the five tricks to
develop unstoppable confidence check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there confidence is the
willingness to try my character my
personality a lot of that came from
martial art it's no doubt in my mind you
should really go to a retirement home
one day and volunteer and just talk to
them